فماذا عن النوايا ولكن قبل ذلك ماذا عن
لغه الارقام قبيل الانتخابات المرتقبه يا
طاهر
بعيدا عن البرامج الانتخابيه والوعود
الرنانه لغه استطلاعات الراي لا تزال
وتعطي الحظوظ الاوفر في الفوز لاردوغان
حيث اشارت نتائج استطلاعات للراي اجرتها
مؤسسات تركيه متخصصه الى ان حزب العداله
والتنميه سيتصدر نتائج الانتخابات
البرلمانيه وان الرئيس اردوغان سيفوز
بولايه رئاسيه ثالثه متقدما على خصومه
التقليديين وتوقع استطلاعهم للراي اجره
مركز ان يصوت نحو 38 بالمئه اردوغان للفوز
بمنصب الرئيس في حين قال 34%
اصواتهم لرئيس حزب الشعب الجمهوري المعارض
كمال
اخرى توقعت النتيجه ذاتها وهي فوز اردوغان
من بينها استطلاع مؤسسه سوسيو ميديا حيث
اكد و30% من المستطلات ارائهم انهم
سيختارون اردوغان لولايه جديده بين ما جاء
في المرتبه الثانيه رئيس حزب الشعب
الجمهوري بنسبه 33% اما استطلاع الراي
الذي اجراه مركز اوراسيا فقد توقع فوز حزب
الشعب جمهوري بالانتخابات البرلمانيه لكنه
تنبا بفوز اردوغان بالانتخابات الرئاسيه
وفيما يتعلق بنتائج الاستطلاعات التي
اجرتها من الصفر تويتر والتي بلغ عددها 16
استطلاعا فقد اكد التقدم اردوغان بفارق
مريح نسبيا عن كمال
[موسيقى]
برايي النظام البرلماني افضل في السابق
كانت الانظمه والقوانين تدافع عن حقوق
الشعب وليس عن الاشخاص حاليا ما يقوله شخص
واحد هو الذي يسري
سابقا خلال النظام البرلماني واجهنا ازمات
كثيره لذلك انا اؤيد ان يكون الرئيس
شخص حاليا